stephan kulle ja wir können über eine
menge themen reden heute hier die im
parlament besprochen werden um
beispielsweise über den nationalen
bildungsbericht der diskutiert wird wir
könnten über aktuelle stunde zum thema
lobbyismus reden über myanmar wozu ist
auch eine aktuelle stunde geben wird wir
können über änderungen am
abgeordnetengesetz sprechen wo es um
ordnungsgelder geht aber die lage ist
klar wir müssen weiter reden über corona
und die folgen und die maßen haben
dagegen unter war das stichwort schon
gern von stephan kulle es geht um die
fortgeltung der epidemischen lage
nationaler tragweite was wiederum ein
gesetzentwurf ist der hier eingebracht
wird der wiederum sich auswirkt auf eine
ganze reihe anderer gesetze
beispielsweise das
infektionsschutzgesetz aber wir müssen
natürlich auch reden über die beschlüsse
die gestern getroffen worden sind in der
bund länder und die sichere und um die
bundeskanzlerin zusammen geschaltet
hatte und wir wollen gucken wie das
eingeschätzt wird auf der einen seite
von den koalitionsfraktionen aber auch
aus der opposition ich freue mich dass
heute morgen bei uns in carsten
schneider der erste parlamentarische
geschäftsführer der spd-fraktion und
leif erik holm ist bei uns der
stellvertretende vorsitzende der
spd-fraktion hier im deutschen bundestag
einen guten morgen ihnen beiden
herr schneider ihr fraktionsvorsitzender
hat am dienstag von berechtigten
wünschen der bevölkerung und auch aus
der wirtschaft gesprochen und behutsame
öffnung gefordert auf nachfrage hat er
dann auch gesagt der gesundheitsschutz
spiele weiter auch eine große rolle
wo entsprechen die ergebnisse von
gestern abend diesen wünschen sie sind
weitestgehend darin abgebildet weil wir
jetzt ist erst mal der andere
perspektive in der pandemie annehmen
können nämlich nicht nur die die versuch
der isolierung von menschen in dem man
sich dass keine kontakte hat bis auf den
engsten familienkreis hin zu einer
öffnung von schulen kitas und dem
gesellschaftlichen leben
das schritt für schritt je nachdem wie
die ja die infektionszahlen sich
entwickeln
im zweifel wenn sie durch die decke
gehen sollten wir es in tschechien in
teilen ja sehen dann auch wieder zurück
zu gehen aber ich glaube dass wir mit
der möglichkeit erster viel stärker noch
zu impfen den nächsten wochen werden die
endlich genügend impfstoff haben er
wurde
der hauptpunkt sein wird kriegen die
möglichst schnell auch vererbt oder zum
zweiten
auch mit einer durchdachten strategie
auch zu gucken wo sind infektionsherd
und da kommen die arbeitgeber auch in
die pflicht ich werde das ganze nämlich
auch machen müssen und auch dafür die
kosten tragen die fläche war generell
gegen den lock down aber hat speziell ab
januar noch mal gefordert jetzt müsse
endgültig aufgehoben werden obwohl man
ja auch von der anderen seite sagen muss
ein richtiger locker so ein richtiger
wie man es beispielsweise in frankreich
hatte ist das ja trotz allem nicht
gewesen jetzt öffnungs schritte
skizziert da müssen sie doch einigen
zustimmen können nein damit sind wir
ganz und gar nicht zufrieden wir sehen
ja dass dieser locker und weitergeführt
wird wir sind jetzt bereits im fünften
monat dieses lockdown und das nochmal
bis ende märz weiter zu führen
das bricht vielen unternehmen in unserem
land das genick es ist ja immer eine
abwägungsfrage nun ist es ja
mittlerweile zum glück so dass in den
alten und pflegeheim weitestgehend
geimpft wurde
das heißt auch dieser grund fällt weg
denn die meisten menschen sind ja in den
alten und pflegeheim gestorben
übrigens auch das geht das oft das konto
der bundesregierung diesen nicht
vermocht hat wenigstens zu zweiter werde
dafür zu sorgen dass in den alten und
pflegeheime test strategie da ist dass
da wirklich immer geschaut wird dass da
keine kontakte auftauchen mit
infizierten personen das hätte man
frühzeitig machen müssen so dieser grund
ist jetzt aber weggefallen zum glück der
und deswegen ist es jetzt geboten auch
endlich die wirtschaft wieder machen zu
lassen wir sehen heute die zahlen der
lufthansa 6,7 milliarden verlust wie
haben gerade neun milliarden investiert
davon ist also zwei drittel schon wieder
weg und die briten die haben jetzt ganz
an steigende buchungszahlen können
wieder los fall fast die hälfte der
bürger dort die sich impfen lassen
wollte auch geimpft wurde
ich weiß noch mal zusammen oder versuche
zu übersetzen sie sagen locker und ende
jetzt sofort und auf der stelle
und das in einer situation wo wir heute
wieder 11.000 neue infektionszahlen
haben also infektionen sind stabil aber
wir sehen doch die inzidenz die inzidenz
zahlen sind doch auch nicht sehr
aussagekräftig man muss auf sich schauen
das ist ein aber ein schlechter
indikator denn je mehr wir testen und
wir wollen ja nun eine test strategie
hinein kommen irgendwann wir sehen heute
dass die schnelltests noch nicht mal
bestellt wurden von herrn spahn
also auch da versagen der
bundesregierung aber wenn wir mehr
testen finden wir auch mehr fälle das
heißt die incident zahl bleiben per se
hoch dann haben wir die falsch positiven
fälle also es wird immer eine
höhere instanz gehen wir können uns auf
diese basis nicht versteifen
deswegen machen wir jetzt auch eine
gesetzesänderung darauf einzugehen
im bundestag wo wir die fragen jetzt
gleich in der ersten lesung also der
zweiten lesung zum
infektionsschutzgesetz wohl weitere
aspekte einbeziehen können die inzidenz
zahl ist nicht der einzige wert der eine
berücksichtigung findet bei der frage
was wird geöffnet was nicht sondern ist
auch die frage wie viele leute in den
krankenhäusern wie hoch die
intensivbetten belastung wie viele der
über 80-jährigen sind geimpft auch der
zwischen 60 und 80 jährigen und da
kommen jetzt einfach in ein viel
besseres system denn herum halt recht
den großteil dieser gruppe ist jetzt
gifte dementsprechend wird die rat der
die todesfälle sind nichtsdestotrotz
bedeutet diese krankheit auch für einige
junge sieht das in großbritannien eine
große gefahr und deswegen kann man das
auch nicht klein reden sondern muss
behutsam vorgehen
jetzt sagen sie die inzidenz werte
spiele nicht die entscheidende rolle
aber da haben wir gestern diese schöne
grafik gesehen die auf einen din a 4
zettel passt die öffnung schritte die
fünfte jetzt folgen sollen und
obendrüber waren ausschließlich immer
die inzidenz werte als orientierung für
die nächsten schritte die kommen sollen
also ganz so ist es ja nicht dass das
keine rolle mehr spielt sollte er nicht
die entscheiden und alleinige rolle
sondern es gibt den weiteren rosen auch
den erwerb wir machen jetzt das gesetz
das gesetz im bundestag und das ist
maßgeblich bin mir auch sicher dass
regional immer sehr genau geschaut
werden kann und auch muss welche
maßnahmen entschieden werden
nehmen wir ein beispiel bei mir in
weimar man die institute seien immer
sehr gut um die 70 herum
dann hat mir eine neue ausbrüche an
einen privaten träger eines pflegeheims
mit 30 toten todesfällen und darf einmal
ist jetzt durch die decke gegangen und
bei infizierten zahlen das war aber
lokal begrenzt da und deswegen da sind
die wichtigsten orientierungspunkte
aussehen nicht die einzigen wollte ich
damit sagen wir werden noch einige zeit
aufeinander aufpassen müssen auch
abstand halten müssen
ich schätze bis zum juni in dem dreh
herum und das entscheidende ist jetzt
impfen impfen
ich habe immer noch nicht ganz
verstanden wo denn die partei oder ihre
fraktionen inzwischen angekommen ist was
der erkenntnis angeht ob wir hier eine
pandemie haben oder nicht weil man hört
immer wieder einzelne stimmen auch aus
ihrer fraktion die sagen ja kugel 19 ist
da
aber in der pandemie ist es nicht und
dramatisch ist es schon gerade gar nicht
weil hat das vergleichsweise mit den
grippewellen auch immer gegeben wie ist
der stand der dinge bei ihnen also es
kann ja niemand von der hand weisen dass
es sich um eine pandemie handelt die
frage ist wie man damit umgeht und da
macht die bundesregierung aus unserer
sicht viele viele fehler
oder kommt überhaupt nicht voran das
thema impfen angesprochen jens spahn
hatte er immerhin versucht möglichst
schnell an impfstoffe zu kommen da ist
in die kanzlerin in die parade gefahren
so dass wir jetzt immer noch warten auf
die impfdosen die wir eigentlich
bräuchten damit diejenigen die sich
impfen lassen wollen
auch schnell geimpft werden können wir
hängen doch völlig hinterher
die briten wie gesagt haben jetzt über
ein drittel schon geimpft in israel sind
es über 50 gramm fast 60 prozent
mittlerweile wir stehen bei fünf selbst
marco hat uns abgehängt mit 10%
impfquote die doppelte immer quote in
marokko das kann es doch wohl nicht sein
und wenn wir mehr leute geben hätten
dann könnten wir natürlich auch etwas
mehr lockern als das was jetzt geplant
ist
die tests sollen jetzt quasi der
türöffner sein für weitere öffnung
schritte soll schnell getestet werden es
soll auch kostenlos getestet werden dann
kommen die selbsttests in absehbarer
zeit angeblich noch dazu was macht sie
so sicher dass das ganze funktioniert
weil da sind ja doch täuschungen und und
und schummeleien durchaus tür und tor
geöffnet insbesondere bei den selbsttest
andersrum gefragt wie wollen sie
sicherstellen dass das tatsächlich alles
mit rechten dingen zugeht oder wir
wollen sie zu überprüfen und
kontrollieren
wir sind ein freiheitliches land mit
einer verantwortung des einzelnen auch
höher und ich setze auch die
verantwortung jedes einzelnen in
deutschland sonst hätten wir mit 84
millionen menschen auf so engem raum
überleben auch diesen doktoren gar nicht
überlebt im sinne von politische und
auch gesellschaftlich und die
selbsttests da werden sie sehen wenn sie
den nutzen den wird im handel geben ob
sie infiziert sind oder nicht und da
gehe ich mal so wie ich die bevölkerung
in deutschland kenne zuvor bei neun von
zehn davon aus dass er diesen krank sind
infektes dass sie sich dann auch dem pc
ist dass der weitergehende test machen
und auch krank schreiben lassen oder
isolieren
vielleicht gibt es ein oder zwei die das
nicht tun
aber die müssen sie im zweifel kaufen
aber wir können nicht die totale
kontrolle über alles haben und wir
werden damit schon viel viel mehr
infektionen
oder infizierte menschen entdecken
können die sich selbst auch und damit
auch diese ketten durchbrechen ich bin
jedenfalls dagegen dass wir hier ein
regime auf ziehen wo man sich quasi nur
noch also nicht auf der eigenen
verantwortung auch setzt der zweite
punkt ist wird diese selbsttests noch
mal geben sie die die auch von den
unternehmen dann gemacht werden die
puppen auch ein zertifikat letztendlich
kriegt von einem vor dem er von einem
testzentrum die werden mehr sicherheit
geben und werden auch die garantie sein
können dass man sich im öffentlichen
raum vielleicht den geschäften besser
bewegen kann
sie haben das in teilen schon
angesprochen wie würde denn ihre
strategie aussehen für die nächsten
wochen und monate wir müssen jetzt
endlich dafür sorgen dass die
unternehmen wieder arbeiten können es
ist ja das tun sie überwiegend
jahrhundert das tun sie überwiegend dass
da sprechen sie jetzt etwas sehr
gelassen aus was andere nicht zugelassen
leben können sie die arbeit er ist als
arbeitete industrie aber eben doch viele
mittelständler die nicht arbeiten können
750.000 unternehmen sind von der
insolvenz bedroht 750.000 unternehmen
das muss man sich vorstellen das thema
tourismus ist zum beispiel hier in dem
papier überhaupt nicht adressiert bei
mir in mecklenburg vorpommern habe
instanzen in meinem wahlkreis von unter
30 die dürfen nicht aufmachen die
hoteliers die gastronomen keine chance
auf mallorca kann man fliegen bei uns
darf man keinen urlaub banken das ist
doch völlig irre sowas deshalb den
zustand beschrieben
die frage war was würden sie machen wir
wollen öffnen das ist ganz klar wir
müssen den unternehmen jetzt gelegenheit
geben wieder arbeiten zu gehen natürlich
unter einhaltung der abstands und
hygieneregeln das ist völlig klar und
wir brauchen die massive test strategie
wo bleiben denn die tests die noch nicht
mal bestellt sind das ist tatsächlich
ein richtiger weg den wir gehen müssen
wir müssen dafür sorgen dass wir
infektionsketten durchbrechen das geht
natürlich über tests dann müssen wir
aber auch die inzidenz des als absolut
setzen und kaufen hier fast 20 mal drin
auf wir müssen dann die inzidenz zahlen
auch in beziehung setzen zur anzahl der
tests nur dann bekommen wir ein reales
ergebnis auf das wir bauen können
okay da haben wir glaube ich so viel so
viel wissen in der summe dann überhaupt
gar nicht reden wir über die den
gesetzentwurf zur fortgeltung der die
epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite betreffenden regelungen haben
schon gesagt infektionsschutzgesetzes
betroffenen sozialgesetzbuch 5 und
die das pflegezeitgesetz
bevölkerungsschutz gesetze zudem und
einige andere mehr
warum ist das nötig was wir heute machen
wollen weil wir an der die feststellung
der epidemischen lagert dies machte der
bundestag die muss jetzt wieder fällt
neu festgestellt werden weil sie es bis
ende des bis ende märz befristet oder 0
bis dahin entschieden wurden wir
brauchen aber aufgrund der situation
eine verlängerung die haben dieses
gesetz noch mal in vielen punkten an
geschäft auch bei der frage nach welchen
kriterien können dann oder welche gz
welche werte neben den instituten
hinzuzuziehen um grundrechts
einschränkungen in kauf zu nehmen oder
auch anzuweisen oder auch hinzustellen
das ist macht es rechtssicherer und es
ist der ordnungsrahmen für die solchen
und pandemie bekämpfung von daher dieses
gesetz ist notwendig wahrscheinlich
eines der wichtigsten was wir in diesem
jahr noch dieser bundestag noch
beschließen wird
und wir haben die evaluierung auch noch
mit drin er für den nächsten bundestag
sich das wo manche sagen die kommt
eigentlich zu spät
ja ich meine es muss man mit augenmaß
und auch mit sachkenntnis dann auch
machen wenn man darüber hinweg ist um
für die zukunft zu lernen ich glaube wir
sind mitten noch in einem lernprozess
das sind einige fehler gemacht oder
überhaupt nicht bestreiten
und die werden wir auch für dieses
gesetz ohne überlegung für den nächsten
bundestag quasi mit einbringen weil wir
bei der seuchenbekämpfung glaube ich mit
dieser starken die wir hatten einiges
noch lernen müssen fortgeltung der
epidemischen lage richtig oder falsch
heraus
wir haben eine epidemische lage das ist
durchaus der fall aber dass wir was wir
beschließen sollen
das führt natürlich zu weit ich habe es
angesprochen wir müssen jetzt in die
öffnung hineingehen wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass diejenigen die betroffen
sind von dieser pandemie geschützt
werden das ist in den alten und
pflegeheim dort wo die meisten menschen
gestorben sind geregelt also das
brauchen wir nicht mehr wir müssen jetzt
eine öffnung hin bekommen deswegen den
wir das auch entsprechen dann würden sie
es anders formulieren würden sie andere
vorgaben machen in diesem zu dieser
fortgeltung die der heute zu diesem
gesetzentwurf der heute beschlossen
werden soll oder würden sie generell
sagen in bonn begann
die brauchen wir nicht so festgestellt
weil wir glauben dass es jetzt zeit es
die grundrechte wie herzustellen wir
erleben ja jetzt ein völliges
überschießen auch des staates in
vielerlei hinsicht wenn wir uns die
dinge anschauen die draußen passieren da
sind jogger unterwegs auf freier strecke
die werden angehalten weil sie keinen
mundschutz tragen und so weiter und so
fort wir haben so viele dinge die falsch
laufen und ich glaube das brauchen wir
jetzt einfach nicht mehr wir brauchen
eine öffnung damit unsere unternehmen
wieder arbeiten können die nämlich genau
das finanzieren auch das
gesundheitswesen dass wir im moment so
stadt brauchen abschließend glauben sie
denken sie beide dass die beschlüsse von
gestern ehren signal sind dann die
bevölkerung dass sie sich wieder
entspannter und lockerer verhalten
können auf abstände nicht mehr so achten
müssen weil die politiker
lockerungsschritte gehen will oder
denken sie dass die leute so vernünftig
sind dass ich sagen okay verstehe ich
muss mich zusammenreißen irgendwie dann
erreiche ich das so dass ich hoffe das
sehr denn wir haben im freien kaum
infektionen deswegen ist der punkt wo
countries beispiel würde ich bestätigen
das ist quatsch ist eine
übersprungshandlung die dann auch wenn
kirchen im zweifel zurückgezogen oder
von den politisch verantwortlichen und
wir brauchen aber auch wenn es noch um
die schulen offen halten zu können die
ja im innenraum stattfinden für die
bildung der kinder ist es entscheidend
dass sie es können brauchen wir gerade
im privaten keine partys keine feiern
abstand halten dann schauen was in drei
monaten auch ich bin gestern am tag
wieder eine runde gelaufen bin ich ein
einziges mal angehalten worden übrigens
seit seit über einem jahr war gestern
wieder große gruppen zusammensitzen
sehen und zusammenstehen sehr eng sehr
nahe sehr dicht und habe mich dann schon
gefragt ob die botschaft die da gestern
später im laufe des abends angekommen
ist vielleicht dann doch die richtige
ist was ist aus ihrer sicht die
botschaft von gestern
das ist eine gute frage dazu müsste man
erst mal durch steigen was da an
beschlüssen gefasst worden ist da muss
man ja schon sehr sehr lange studieren
und otto normalbürger kann das gar nicht
nachvollziehen dass ein afghane hat ono
mal unter uns unter anderem aber gut
ja aber sie sehen es doch also diese
diese seiten die wir hier lesen wir
sehen diese riesen tabelle die niemand
versteht der bürger kommt doch gar nicht
mehr mit mit diesen ganzen region kann
das gar nicht nachverfolgen da muss
günstigstenfalls den ganzen tag über
arbeiten also gesorgt
was heißt regeln wir brauchen natürlich
regeln aber wir können diese strategie
nicht weiter fortsetzen
das ist klar wir brauchen jetzt wieder
freiheit für die bürger
für die unternehmen abstands und hygiene
regeln sind natürlich einzuhalten das
ist auch wichtig jetzt ist unsere zeit
zu ende ich hätte gerne noch über den
ständigen epidemie mit ihnen gesprochen
aber das haben wir nicht geschafft ruhe
vielleicht irgendwann mal nach also
klingt so ein bisschen nachbarn emirat
denen auch die grünen wollen und ähnlich
herr schneider vielen dank dass sie
heute hier weil sie müssen rein flitzen
auch ihnen vielen dank herr holm